on va démarrer direct avec une cuisine
question twitter le premier tweet de la
soirée il est pour qui toute question
twitter tout de suite ses partenaires de
mathieu delormeau juste une question
pourquoi intacte est revenu alors on va
rappeler ce qu'on dit la vérité ce soir
à jeudi
il ya eu toute la polémique l'année
dernière derrière mathieu on se rappelle
en loge avec tout le monde c'est vrai
que des frictions dit la vérité
allez-y vous avec votre oreille un alesi
l'hôtel enlève des bouts de cire mais
comme ça la vie de ma mère l'hôtel
enlève de faire assez débouta qu'elle a
dans le sang royal dauphin un truc de
ouf
mathieu d'eau qu'il ya eu toute la
polémique en loge ça a été très très
chaud avec ni parce que j'avais fait un
débrief après vous êtes parti on va le
pam entretenir en claquant la porte
ouais et aujourd'hui il y a donc si
bastien qui vous demande pourquoi vous
êtes revenue service était très très
chaud ne jamais castaldi a voulu me
casser la gueule
disons la vérité c'est vrai autant de la
vérité sans gardant le meilleur mais
dans le pire
non il n'a pas voulu il est énervé guéna
grève énervé oui car on s'est échangé
des méchancetés anathèmes et c'est vrai
que c'est vrai qu'il ya eu il ya eu une
sorte de petit procès un peu dans la
loge
j'ai pas apprécié j'ai claqué la porte
et c'est vrai que quand je suis parti
dans ma tête je me suis vraiment dit
c'est fini je suis parti flamand et
d'ailleurs on sait plus adresser la
parole tous y compris avec vous pendant
un mois un mois et demi vous envoyer des
petits sms c'est vrai faut que je n'ai
pas répondu ouais j'ai la vérité et puis
un jour vous envoyez moi un sms en
disant rester pour le point d'orgue un
truc de boulot je me suis dit de me
répondre un peu fragments et vous m'avez
répondu un truc était hyper mignon ça me
fait trop plaisir tant sms ou ça voyons
nous on doit demain matin pour un petit
déjeuner ensemble
j'y suis allé un petit peu sur la pointe
des pieds et quand vous avez vu on a
pris le petit déj jeudi tu sais je paye
pas changé après les séries où les
parents j'ai après ouais ranger après
merci et pour être sincère quand il a
pris son petit déjeuner là on a on a
rigolé comme quand même comme avant cet
état de chose qu'est ce qu'on va se dire
et en fait on a passé une heure et demie
a vraiment rigoler c'est reparti comme
avant et finalement on a été assez était
très sincère ce jour là et ils vous
tuent mais vous m'avez dit si vous
voulez revenir si tu veux revenir tu
viens tu veux pas revenir tu viens pas
voilà et puis on a discuté un petit peu
des conditions génique tête j'ai fait
trop d'émissions aussi la dernière
tous les jours à la fin j'étais un peu
fatigué tout ça c'est dit on va en faire
deux à trois est ce que vous êtes voilà
franchement a dit moi la vérité mathieu
est ce que vous êtes heureux avec nous
aujourd'hui
cette année c'est parfait vraiment avoir
fait la première année c'est formidable
la deuxième année la dernière je dire la
vérité ça c'était c'était moins bien
pour moi c'est plus compliqué plus de
mettre ma place plus de mal dans les
rapports avec vous souvent s'engueuler
tout ça mais c'est vrai qu'on peut
s'engueuler avec vous pour être très
honnête si vous arrive avant l'émission
étupes oui cette année c'est parfait
j'en fais deux à trois par semaine c'est
le rythme parfait sur content d'être là
on ne s'est pas engueulé une seule fois
jamais tous les deux avec l'équipe aussi
pour moi cette année c'est parfait donc
vous êtes heureux à traire je suis très
content parce qu'on fait un bisou les
séries géraldine est en train de tourner
en ce moment un documentaire sur les
coulisses de tpm pc vraiment les yeux
dans tpm pays et justement on a des
images de la réunion avant le retour de
mathieu même moi je les connais pas je
vais découvrir giraldi vous nous avez
passé ces images oui j'ai après a priori
je sais pas du tout ce cas mais j'ai
briefé l'équipe une minute ça dure une
minute alors que la séquence dans le sim
sur le retour de matthieu delormeau dure
plus de cinq minutes mais donc c'est
juste le début vous n'aviez briefé dans
votre dans votre loge comme d'habitude
et c'est un bon moment j'avais trouvé
que ces termes je le découvre comme vous
sur mathieu je veux pas que ça tourne au
truc du genre ouais l'udc était un tu
vois il faut pas que ça tombe un peu
glauque
il faut que ce soit toujours dans la
rigolade mais dans le dans l'esprit de
fans c'est à dire bien sûr une actualité
déçu de trucs comme ça sur deûle en vous
les gens attendent quand même une
explication c'est à dire que si on fait
il arrive qu'ils ont fait comme si de
rien n'était il a les mêmes au masters
fracassé vous voyez la question que vous
voulez d'accord franchement lorsque
course assez court et c'est vrai donc ça
s'est très bien passé s'est très bien
passé et si je dois dire toute la vérité
zidi travers y en a qu'un qui avait eu
une réaction que j'ai pas compris ce
vraiment parce que je m'entendais très
bien vécu c'était jean luc lemoine et si
je suis très très très honnête depuis
cette première émission et c'était un
peu froid on s'est retrouvés mais c'est
pas comme avant cinar et qu'ils avoir
une coordination aujourd'hui parce que
je serais lui et si je peux vous je peux
je vais je vais parler au nom d'une
lutte qui est vraiment mon ami 20
jean-luc c'est un garçon qui est très
entier il donne sa confiance à kate qui
a des difficultés à donner sa confiance
et une fois qu'il l'a donnée quand il
est déçu c'est très très dur de
l'arganier moi je dollars gagnés voit la
petite île à tizi mais jean-luc c'est un
garçon qui est vraiment au qinghai
moi j'ai une confiance vraiment aveugle
et c'est un garçon sur qui on peut
compter à tout moment c'est vraiment
c'est un ami vraiment proche de l'udc et
je vous dis c'est pour ça il a été déçu
et quand jean luc est déçu voilà et ben
forcément derrière il n'y a plus de mal
à se réconcilier avec lui moi je vous
dis mais je doute pas que voilà jean luc
il est aussi intelligent et c'est un peu
froide en septembre est un petit dîner
bah voilà fait un petit dîner il veut
inviter à déjeuner
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jean luc annaix dans une interview
aujourd'hui effectivement il avait eu du
mal à ton retour mais qu'au fur et à
mesure cette sas était reparti et que
maintenant il était à nouveau très très
heureux d'être comme la cote alors en
route notre c'est notre vrai mention
d'un détecteur de mensonges humain
est-ce qu'il a menti là non je pense pas
qu'il a menti par contre si vous
permettez que je pose juste une petite
question mathieu pourquoi vous vous êtes
gratter la tête au moment où vous avez
dit tout est parfait à qui la veut dire
que ça beaucoup de questions
donc pour moi vous n'y étiez pas sûr du
tout que tout était parfait et ben
pourtant je le dis franchement non
peut-être que j'ai élargi de tentes et
de toiles a quand même si la question
est ce que c'est parfait sur ces 8 non
si la question est ce que c'est parfait
sûreté pmp la réponse est oui avait vu
l'ours est grave